everybody poops dude that girl you
really like she poops that guy you like
she poops your dad he poops your dog he
poops so what are we talking about poop
more this next week I will be pooping
using the squatty potty I have heard
about the process of squatting while
pooping being the proper form
we're pooping like dis and it's like
hard for like like the poop to come out
of our butts when really we should be
like pooping like this it's one of those
products like I've always wanted to try
but like low-key I'm kind of I don't
want to say embarrassed to try like
Timmy to try I would really love to
streamline the process I'm a very busy
person in a given poop session I go
through like 30 different sheets of
toilet paper that's what I'm hoping to
get out of this it's like an easy
cleanup if I can find a better way to
poop maybe that might bring me more
peace poop better all right man I'm
ready to take you to my poop palace and
let's see if just [ __ ] now the toilet I
mean sitting on the toilet all right my
feets are elevated it's time to begin my
blog and while I'm pooping yep is it
weird no I mean you see dogs pooping on
this dreams totally fine
well I've update that was an awesome
poop usually it takes me a while
constipation is a real thing not to be
graphic but it just came right out of
there just wet on down it was a smooth
process just because it's not common for
us it makes it feel a little awkward
having to like put up your feet after
you sit on the toilet my bowels are
empty and my heart is full because if
poop was fast cleanup was easy first
poop successful day - I just took
another poop on a squatty
and honestly I had better luck the first
day too much information alert one thing
I'm realizing is they feel like it lets
a lot more poop out so I just went to
the bathroom and I tried to not use a
squatty potty just at the beginning just
to see you know if it was a placebo
effect to see if like oh it's shiny its
new what's helping me poop but let me
tell you I was sitting on the toilet for
30 minutes before anything happened slid
that puppy right under my feet
smooth sailin squatty potty has been
used even by my guests that come to my
house she had her first squatty potty
poop
how was it Oh better than expected I
would say it did help but I did almost
die getting on I'm thinking of maybe by
the way they're like angles your legs
helps you to release more which I would
assume is probably a really good thing
like dating might be a little bit better
I got a report poop number 3 was awesome
sitting on the toilet nothing's
happening guys I used the squatty potty
this morning first thing you know just
for a little uh earlier load out it was
perfect man they do have some
disappointing news one thing that is
really hoping with this is that it would
make wiping easier but I think that was
just my delusional optimism because
poops still coming out and you still got
a wipe so I think I just need to finally
admit I'm a damn adult and I need to
learn how to wipe my butt that was a
beautiful experience it was just like
pressing inject foot in our butt
I'm getting used to it I don't think
it's odd anymore I am I actually like
going to the bathroom now and using the
squatty potty even when I'm not proving
the squatty potty has gotten my poop
time down at least 15 minutes my
bathroom was pretty tiny I like the fact
that I can slide it in between my toilet
and my sink to number four was great I
use it for us a week just finished poo
number five it was fast easy clean and
dare I say fine when I was at work today
I had to poop I found myself looking for
a squatty potty you really can't beat
those efficient poops like ml I just
kept it all together and just waited
till I got home it wasn't the best idea
but you know what I went for it and I'm
so glad that I had the squatty potty
here honestly day five I'm more grateful
than ever that the squatty potty has
been gifted to me um and yeah this video
is sponsored by squatty potty
it's just sponsored by a guy who really
wants you to have the best poop that you
can I'm going to the squatty father you
going to this body buddy
[Music]